[Musique]
vous partez à l'eau
et vous revenez tout de suite
pas de visites guidées et pas des
cessions
seigneur
fait de moi un instrument de ta paix
là où sont les ténèbres que je mets de
la lumière
lahouel athis-mons marcoule union c'est
bien pour ça que je voulais à kadir
cette connerie d'expédition pour éviter
des morts inutiles
c'était pas inutile
restons guelma je suis chargé de
protéger tout le monde et c'est moi qui
décide comment la whey la tristesse que
je mette la choix
[Musique]
au seigneur
je cherche
à comprendre ça prouve que son cerveau
fonctionne
il évolue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au moment où maman
on ressuscite à l'éternel puis